une pratique du français qui parfois
bien du mal à résister à certaines
influences inutile d'aller très loin
dans le tout petit luxembourg on attend
toujours la création d'un lycée français
et l'on parle plus volontiers l'allemand
reportage de laurent dressed notre et
d'actions européens 183 élèves répartis
en neuf classes 30 professeurs dont un
seul payé par la france
l'enseignement français au luxembourg
c'est cela le collège vauban un îlot de
francophonie un peu pauvre dans un pays
dont le français est toujours une des
langues officielles mais désormais
derrière l'allemand il est vrai qu'on
n'a pas créé ici le lycée français
attendus dans les années 60 c'est donc
désormais le luxembourgeois qui règne
ici en première langue mais chouette me
mokrane as donc nous parle nous voulons
bien sûr parler de lui c'est un bon
choix parce que c'est notre lente
certes le luxembourg est un pays riche
mais de là à laisser à l'initiative
privée la création de l'établissement
il y avait une marge résultat les
collages coûte ici de six à dix mille
francs français par trimestre les
professeurs se sentent abandonnés et
inquiet les subventions
c'est vrai tombe rarement et je crois
qu'il faut qu'on nous aide je crois
qu'il faut qu'on constate que notre
travail est important puisque le
luxembourg et dans un environnement
germanique et que la puissance voisine
est quand même la grande allemagne feu
vert de l'europe pour la peau